that's so good so I have a scar that I
got when I was three years old my on was
taking care of me at the time and she
instead of sitting me down in a
highchair like a normal three year old
kid I was sat down in a regular chair
she served me this bowl of soup and for
a second she turned around and I pour
the hot bowl of soup on myself
covering my chest my right arm and my
Riley I had third-degree burns and I
still have the scar on my chest I have a
scar here that I got from playing
basketball last year it was a freak
accident
I got tripped up and when I woke up I
saw my knee cap lodged it might die I
called my mom she rushed me to the ER
the doctor basically said that I have a
ruptured patellar tendon this tendon
from my kneecap to my shin bone had
ruptured and exploded there was nothing
keeping these two things connected so
basically my leg would go limp kind of
like that so we're here at the Warren
tattoo to get a tattoo to cover up my
scar so you're wanting to incorporate
your scar like me not actually cover it
all but sort of yeah I definitely don't
want to cover it up just cuz it's been
with me my whole life but I do want
something honored to kind of bring it
together I'm like very Mexican and so
like I wanted to be with my background
and so I'm obsessed with the Y at los
Muertos the schools and the flowers so I
do want to quote probably somewhere
around here or here she actually has a
flower tattoo as well it was kind of
like when she went through depression -
and you know I just kind of want to get
the same flower like here and do you
want that to be actually
yeah the scars like stem I'm nervous I'm
excited when I walk into the house the
first thing I saw was he was very red
and he had blisters on his chest and I
rushed him to the hospital they told me
to put him on the hospital bed and he
was crying and screaming and she keep
holding into me and saying no mommy
please no no so they made me to mom
[Music]
this is for you yeah hey yeah else did
this kind of here
[Applause]
I saw him sat down on the floor then he
came from that wall can explain
you heard your body but you also put in
your heart and you cannot share that you
really want to take a little bit pain
from that person to you to share that
the only thing I can tell him that to be
where you are and I only believe it
anything happened it could be worse it's
always like that first initial pinch so
growing up middle school was tough three
years everybody happy we have to change
I was embarrassed of showing my scars so
I would either change in the bathroom
before going into the locker room or I
would put the [ __ ] underneath and then
just go to school dressed in my t-shirt
I feel like that's always something I've
had to deal with as an adult I got a
little bit better about it but I'm still
shy sometimes when it comes to like
taking off my shirt and like showing my
scar
I went through a lot mentally and
obviously physically gonna walk for
three months the surgery recovery itself
was one of the most painful things I've
experienced my life to this day I still
remember every single tipping point that
changed me internally and made me
appreciate the small things in life I
realize that you can't take any little
thing for grants is like walking or even
bending your knee and how important that
is to you everyday life it was a very
tough moment for me and the scar is a
daily reminder of the pain that I felt
then and the pain that I feel now can I
see can I see wow this is it wow it's a
little painful but not as painful as
what I went through I probably will be
taking my shirt off anytime soon
but I am comfortable tattoo to show so
this is my way of saying thank you for
everything if we're taking care of me
and literally helping you stand back up
I will forever have the scar and now
it's kind of cool too I have a tattoo on
it that I will have the rest
gonna look back at this tattoo it's no
longer scar you know it's a piece of me
and a piece of you me my heart is it and
I hate that either rose yeah thanks
I've done this without you man
[Music]
you